former president Donald Trump will make
his first public appearance since
learning he will be charged with dozens
of federal crimes on Friday the justice
department unsealed its 49-page
indictment Trump is facing 37 charges
related to his storing of classified
documents after he left the White House
the charges also include obstruction
conspiracy and making false statements
to investigators Trump maintains his
innocence he'll make his first court
appearance in Miami on Tuesday but today
he'll be speaking to Republican voters
in Georgia and North Carolina Scott
McFarland is in Greensboro North
Carolina Scott good morning to you
good morning
and and what can you uh tell us at this
stage take us inside the indictment and
specifically what stood out to you with
how prosecutors made this case
This truly historic document alleges not
just a crime Michelle but a cover-up it
has these resonant Echoes of Watergate
the former presidents accused of not
only concealing and potentially exposing
America's most sensitive Secrets its
nuclear secrets military secrets in a
ballroom in a bedroom in a bathroom in
Mar-A-Lago but according to the charging
documents he worked to circumvent the
efforts to rescue or retrieve those
records either working through his
attorneys or trying to work around his
attorneys also noteworthy and some of
the granular detail in the charging
documents the former presidents accused
of showing at least some of these
records to a writer to a member of a
political action committee these are
federal charges and it's worth leaning
into that point the former president of
the United States accused of a crime
against the United States
yes Scott so the former president's now
been indicted in two jurisdictions for
two completely different sets of charges
that's also not the only legal Jeopardy
he's in what what else can you tell us
about that
but let's start off with the special
counsel Jack Smith Jeff he has shown
some of his cards in this new indictment
but only some there's still an
investigation into efforts to overturn
the 2020 election results that Jack
Smith is leading through his special
counsel office including what became of
all the money raised based on baseless
claims of fraud in the election and also
what gave rise to January 6 that is
epicentered in Washington D.C there's
also the investigation with a grand jury
in Fulton County Georgia in Atlanta into
efforts by Trump and others to overturn
Georgia's 2020 election results there
are already two trains on two different
tracks in which Donald Trump is a
passenger there can be two more and all
of them will move along potentially
simultaneously
so he's set to make his first court
appearance in this case on Tuesday what
can we expect to actually see come
Tuesday
we might not see much of anything Dana
the federal court system prohibits
cameras inside the courtroom inside the
courthouse they do take booking photos
inside the U.S Marshal's office the
former president will have a booking
photo taken but in the federal system
they don't release booking photos we
also know most if not all federal
courthouses have private entrances for
high-profile Witnesses high-profile
defendants or those who are in
Marshall's custody and pre-trial
detention it's possible the former
president could be ushered into the
courthouse out of sight it's an initial
appearance and an arraignment Tuesday in
Miami this could take just a matter of
minutes he'll enter a plea of guilty or
not guilty to talk about some release
conditions and then this case heads to a
judge Who was appointed by Trump himself
all right Scott just the beginning of
things yet again thank you